[Music]
my name is Rene hajeck I'm a faculty
member at the Dunlap Institute in the
Department of astronomy and astrophysics
at the University of Toronto so I like
to tell people that I'm a cosmologists
which means that my job is looking at
the sky the same way you do but asking
and answering fundamental questions
about what the universe is made of I'm
also from the southern hemisphere which
is means I'm partial to the southern
hemisphere sky you can see here these
two beautiful fuzzy blobs or galaxies
these are the large and small Magellanic
Clouds but really if I'm honest my job
is to try and figure out the puzzle
pieces of the universe hopefully you
will have got a sense today from the
fact that we have so many interesting
observations that we're making and also
interesting questions about the nature
of the universe so if we look at this
picture this represents a timeline of
the universe and we start with the Big
Bang this hot energetic phase and we
have cosmic microwave background
radiation and we know we also live today
and we looking back in time at this
history but putting all these pieces
together is not an easy task and one
thing that you will have seen today is
that we will stop at nothing to do it
so the telescope that I'm one of the
collaborations that I'm involved in is
the Atacama cosmology telescope so this
telescope is located high up in the
North it does deserts of northern Chile
so it's 5,200 metres above sea level and
it's an incredibly dry place we look at
the Cosmic Microwave Background again
and we measure very fine resolution of
these these images to try and piece
together what the this light is telling
us about the initial conditions of the
universe and also galaxies and dark
matter through lensing you saw that we
do the same thing from the South Pole so
our colleagues at the South Pole
telescope do much of the same research
that we do and this is
two really important because we want to
get to a deeper understanding of the
universe and that means some element of
that is looking at the same things with
different groups we think differently we
approach problems differently and we
have different experiments and this
creates a really productive and fruitful
scientific endeavor as we cross check
each other and make sense of things now
we like dry places we like sometimes
cold places or if Mia Atacama it's also
pretty cold
we sometimes decide you know what the
ground isn't isn't what we want we send
things into space and so Bart told you
about spider the ambitious project of
sending up balloons to measure again the
Cosmic Microwave Background
so here it's the same radiation as the
the kind that myself and my colleagues
measure from the South Pole but we're
doing it in a different way to try and
answer slightly different questions
about the universe but of course we're
wavelength independent you heard from
people today that are using radio waves
even longer waves to understand not only
the energetics of these really
incredible extreme objects but to
measure something about space itself and
gravitational radiation even deep
underground we have experiments that are
measuring the small distortions of space
that come because of gravitational waves
or hunting for these incredible dark
matter particles so if there's a
wavelength of light if there's a place
in the unity on earth we will find it
and we will try and do science from that
place we even send things into space and
so this is a video of the Planck
satellite that was mentioned a couple of
times and we same plank up to try and
get away from the atmosphere because
when you're measuring microwaves as was
mentioned before it helps to have as
little of our Earth's atmosphere between
you and the cosmos these photons have
been traveling a long distance we need
to give them every break that they can
and Planck scans the sky and makes
measurements of the full sky and allows
us to measure not only small patches but
really the whole sky and tell us
something about these initial conditions
and these fluctuations and again the
physics is similar but we're approaching
it from every angle we can to try and
make progress on these fun
mental questions we don't only learn
about the far-off cosmos so I'm
highlighting the galaxies that I showed
you before this is an image in visible
light of the large and small Magellanic
Clouds but we can look at an image from
Planck where those same two galaxies and
I'll go back on now read kind of
splurges and that is because Planck is
measuring the light that these objects
are giving off as they radiate as the
dust in them radiates and so we can
measure with different wavelengths as it
has been described by many of the
speaker's today we can use different
wavelengths to approach the same objects
and to learn something new about them
you actually notice in this image a lot
of cool foldings it seems of the image
this is a beautiful technique but
there's something scientific
in those foldings that's actually
telling us about the polarization of the
light and that tells us about our own
galaxy's magnetic field so we only don't
only use one property of out light we
don't use its temperature but we measure
its polarization the slight kind of
distortions that are induced by our own
galaxy and also by these early cosmic
gravitational waves to try and build up
this picture we also use extreme objects
like supernovae in a different way so my
research actually focuses not on that
the supernovae that you heard about
today which are big massive stars ending
their lives and exploding but a
different kind of supernova if you
thought you would get away with only
hearing about one cool extreme exploding
star you were wrong these are supernova
we believe are actually happening
because of one very massive white dwarf
pulling material from its companion and
we use these as standard candle so to
explain why these are important I want
to you imagine that you are on a very
dark Street in Toronto maybe Don Mills
Road and there has been a huge hurricane
that knocked out all the power so this
happened in in New York City where I
used to live and this is an image taken
by an artist during during that time so
this is downtown Manhattan after
Hurricane sandy and there were no street
lamps so they were obviously caused
because people in New York and never
stopped no matter what
but if you were a person like me
jaywalking even though I know I probably
shouldn't you want to know how to if
it's safe to cross the road and so what
you do is you look at the headlamps of
the oncoming traffic and if they are
bright you know it's not safe to cross
the road you'll probably get hit by a
car and if they're dim you know that the
car is probably far away and you can
cross the road
everyone who's lived in a city knows how
to do this but have you ever asked
yourself how you know how to do this
of course you learn by experience but it
relies on a fundamental assumption it
relies on the assumption that all
headlamps are created equally bright
intrinsically so that you can use the
difference in the brightness as a
distance indicator in fact if you take
your car to get it serviced they will
check that the headlamps are in fact the
correct brightness a standard brightness
so we use this concept of a standard
headlamp or a standard brightness object
and we use supernovae in the same way
because of the physics of these
explosions we believe that they explode
when they're all roughly the same
brightness and have the same chemical
composition and this is an image that
Scott showed you before of a very bright
supernova exploding in the outskirts of
its galaxy and if we measure these
objects all over the sky they tell us
something about the distance to them and
because we can measure if that distance
is what we expect with without this dark
energy component that we've heard about
a lot today we actually can constrain
through the expansion of space what the
universe is made of in that way we take
this complicated puzzle that seems to
have no order and we start putting the
pieces back together and we come up with
a picture that starts at early times
that has this hot dense phase of
radiation and then the universe becomes
opaque and neutral and slowly stars
start to form we haven't spoken too much
about that today but that's an
incredibly and interesting and as yet
not fully probed part of astronomy and
then later we find galaxies form and the
universe starts to be dominated by dark
energy and starts to expand and this
really rich history is shown on the sky
for us you will know from today that we
like pie charts I believe they were 5
and I am no exception so we
of pie charts that show you the
composition of various things in the
universe and we go from things we know
which are always tiny slivers to things
we don't know which are huge cool
exciting slivers one of which was dark
matter that Mark told you about and the
other is dark energy that affects this
cosmic expansion so what's next for the
universe we know that it's dominated by
dark energy now and will continue the
dark energy will continue to be more and
more important in terms of the total
energy budget of the universe and that
means we can go from the past where we
thought maybe the universe would
decelerate and collapse to understanding
that the universe is going to continue
to accelerate and in fact yet colder and
more empty and more dominated by dark
energy and this came about in the panel
discussion earlier but what's next for
us a lot of the cosmologists that you
heard from today in fact all of us have
huge visions for the future because we
strive as soon as we've come up with one
thing either whether it be a theory or
an observation we want to push to the
next level so I'm involved in a very
ambitious project called a large
synoptic survey telescope or LSST and
alice st has a 3200 megapixel camera
which is about a hundred times as cool
as your phone camera but instead of
taking a tiny image with that camera it
will scan the whole sky once every three
days
so LSST will be able to MIT to measure a
lot of these incredible supernovae and
learn about the expansion of space even
better than we do now I'm also involved
in an ambitious collaboration between
two groups that were previously
competitors so on the summit of the
atacama plateau where we work and the
Atacama cosmology telescope is based
we've joined forces with another group
who on the same plateau called polar
bail that Simon's array and we've become
the Simons Observatory you can see in
this video my colleagues actually
working on a telescope and fitting up
this is act that they're walking around
on and we have decided to join forces to
build the next-generation ground-based
experiments in the Atacama and this will
allow us to take all our minds and that
the problems that we were working on
that was similar and the approaches that
are different and pool our resources to
build the next generation experiment
which will measure this with even
finer precision in fact we're going one
step further and we're actually
combining forces a little bit further
down the road with our colleagues in the
South Pole and we're trying to come up
with the next experiment that will bring
all of these interesting ideas together
to try and say what is the best
instrument that we can build to measure
the light from the earliest times in the
universe we want to measure the large
scales that Bart was interested in and
we want to measure the small scales that
SPT and the Atacama cosmology telescope
are interested in
so hopefully you will have come on a
journey with us through not only the
life of a cosmologists and the things
that we do from both theory to data from
radio data to optical light to
gravitational radiation and the
microwave background but you'll also
have understood that the lifetime of our
universe is really on the sky for us to
see and that we make our lives to try
and figure out the puzzle of the
universe that we find ourselves in
thanks
[Applause]